if they want a season five i'll do a
season five for sure i love this show i
love the people
i don't even know i don't know if they
know exactly when they want to end it
onwards and upwards are you ready for me
to blow your mind
please it has been 634 days
since season three of stranger things
what
yeah mental it dropped july 4th
2019 and we have been left with nothing
for 634 days so gayten i need you
to give me some kind of nugget about
season four what can you tell me
i'll tell you what i can um we're making
it
that's for sure i'm very excited about
it i'm not right now i'm actually home
in new jersey right now so i'm not
working
on on the show now but it's little
increments here and there we get to go
in and film
it's very hard with koben and it's a
it's a big production
and we film a lot of our stuff in big
locations outside with a lot of people
involved and so there's a lot of steps
that need to be made before we can think
about
consistently going into filming i'm
hoping that a big chunk comes up soon
though
and i actually just recently finished
reading the whole season what was your
reaction
i'm pretty stoked how would you describe
the tone of this season do you think you
guys are stepping it up
well i think we kind of have to i think
what the goal for the boys
matt and ross to do is to make sure that
the bar is raised every single season
but
it's raised not too much to a point in
which we couldn't be able to
exceed or even match what we've done
prior
and they're ambitious they are hungry
guys
and they they know what their show is
they know what people like about it
they know what they want and they're
gonna get it too
that's what are they working with them
is like it really is incredible
and when it comes to the tone of the
season it's definitely the tone is
definitely matured
for sure and i think they do that on
purpose because i think they want their
show
to mature with their kids we are growing
older
as people we have to grow older as
characters they're confronted by this
issue
but they embrace it and they use it to
their advantage
and they don't freak out when we get
taller or any or when our voices
drop or anything like that they use it
and they use it as
ammunition for their writing it's
incredible what they can do working with
them is
just exceptional always has been
you've read season four have the
brothers
told you dustin's overall fate do you
know how the show's supposed to end
here's the thing i've heard from them
that
they have a pretty clear idea as to
where they want
to wrap the show up and i think they
have a completely clear outline as to
how they want their show to end but
what's good about them
is that though they have their
conclusion and though they have their
idea
of how they want this to wrap up they're
very keen on letting
it play out by ear this is really clear
in season two when we were filming we
were already filming most of the show
before we had even read
the second half we didn't know much
about it at all and with me and steve
pairing up that was kind of by accident
that was fan favorite for sure but that
was kind of an accident that was pretty
much like there were two characters that
needed to go to the same place and they
were going through pretty similar
dilemmas at the time
they were both dealing with girl trouble
and they basically looked at each other
and were like
all right might as well oh yeah
yeah i still do and we just become best
friends
then they become best but and they let
it play out and that wouldn't have
happened that became clear throughout
the rest of season two and us even being
paired up halfway through that season
was a complete accident so they're very
okay with
letting the path that they've created
diverting to different directions as
long as
it continues in their intended direction
it really is quite cool to see a process
you can play out like that i'm hearing
that the end might take place after
season five
thoughts at the end of what stranger
things that the end might take place
after season five after season five i
don't know about numbers that's all the
business side
that's all stuff that i don't really
like to worry about too much if they
want a season five i'll do a season five
for sure i love this show i love the
people i don't even know i don't know if
they know exactly when they want to end
it i think they know how they want to
end it
i think they know where they want their
characters to be i think the question is
they're just going to figure out they're
going to play by ear and figure out
what's going to go down while they write
sounds like you're on board for this
never-ending story gayten oh man
i don't know maybe we can do like a
spin-off or it's just it's just all of
our kids
really there have been rumors of
spin-offs
would you ever want to do a dustin steve
spin-off henderson
he's back
[Music]
i think a dustin steve spin-off would be
good if it were in like a weird niche
format like they didn't do like a full
show like a wandering like a one edition
type thing or like
a web series type thing where like on
youtube there's like weekly episodes
of little hijinks they get into like
every now and again
like a skit show that'd be great you
kind of break that formatting justin and
steve go to the mall
i don't yeah i don't know if the dustin
and steve full series spin-offs are
sustainable
what are they gonna do for a whole
season just them go to different places
yeah just go them traveling the world
together road trip i liked it
i liked it
[Music]
i loved the fact that we did get to see
dusty bun and suzy pooh
sing for us oh yes in season three
dayton how many people ask you to sing
that song now and could we expect more
singing in season four
it's a substantial number of people it's
a substantial number
of times i've had to hear that song
correct me if i'm wrong on this
but i think that our version of
neverending story
ended up becoming a bigger download on
like spotify or apple music than
the original did like totally in its
peak yeah
i've actually walked down the street and
heard
people listening in their cars to that
version of the song
and i've been like oh gosh it isn't and
i've had to like lean in a little
bit more like yeah that's me that's it
right there it's on the soundtrack it's
literally
on the album for season three which is
epic
it's pretty happy it's pretty epic would
you sing again in season four
would i yeah if they wanted me to
i i don't really have many many
complaints i don't really have many
demands for them but what i can and
can't do they want me to do something
there's very little that will get me not
to do it
what's going on i have no clue you're on
my show prank encounters
have you already pulled a prank on the
set of stranger things
you guys have long days yeah we have
quite long days so
things get tempting for sure actually i
gotta say when it comes to pranksters on
set million noah take the cake for that
one
surprisingly yeah them is a team you get
them together and there's no stopping
them
have you been a victim not to them i've
been victim to them separately not to
them
collectively as a group thank god what
have they done
i know that like uh they've done some
crazy stuff it usually involves the
phone it usually involves them calling
somebody
and telling them something like i
remember somebody on our production was
soon to be married at the time she was
very excited obviously
and i think million noah called her on
herself from like an unknown number
from like a prank dial number and
convinced her
that noah was brian from
the wedding venue and that there was
some crazy accident and they weren't
gonna be able to hold her wedding at the
venue and her wedding's like two weeks
out her wedding was like two weeks out
and she was of course freaking out i
think they let it hang there for a good
couple hours
too if i'm mistaken i wasn't there for
me i'm still fine